camille était quelqu'un d'extrêmement
jovial passionnés personnellement mais
passionné par son travail investi
volontaire dynamique se sont se sont là
ce sont des qualificatifs qui me
viennent à l'esprit quand je pense à
camille
tout le monde le connaît c'est un
personnage pour nous tous est un exemple
aussi camille commentait camille tournai
il n'avait pas d'heure n'est pas de jour
on peut faire son travail et moi un
souvenir que j'en garde
ses talents de mon premier séjour en
martinique
j'étais à l'époque stagiaires font dans
le cadre de mes études de journalisme et
nous avions couvert ensemble la
traversée à la nage de jacques sicot qui
avait relié la martinique à sainte lucie
et j'en garde un souvenir extraordinaire
et c'est vrai que là je j'affiche en
studio pourquoi parce que c'était un
moment merveilleux qu ami m'avait
coacher cadre de ce cursus et cesser sa
vérité en reportage mémorable
franchement je je m'associe à la douleur
de l'ensemble de la station à sa famille
et à ses proches
c'est un choc pour tout le monde c'est
un choc pour moi
mais voilà courage à tous